à sanaa c'est bon on a eu chaud superbe
là c'est bon super d'intervention joli
coup boc maintenant on peut dire à
kasparov que c'est bon ils peuvent faire
mieux maintenant qu'à soi on doit faire
mieux c'est bon t'es sport peut faire
nul il n'y a pas de point d'ailleurs il
a repris du poil de la bête avec ce
changement de cassel territoire ans
ouais ça l'a remis sur les rails usine
harrison ma façon il est au courant
évidemment du nombre de cassettes qui
sont enregistrés ça c'est certain tout à
fait au courant de tout de toute façon
une garry kasparov contrôle tôt à à tour
ces deux tours d'essai de when i'm et
garry kasparov sao moi ou lui ou
qu'est-ce qui sait pas où je sais pas
mais il ya eu un bruit dans le public
il n'était pas content c'est un oued en
public ou c'était non non c'est un vrai
d'un public qui n'a tourné vers le
public autour des ces deux là à j'aime
bien ce plan ces femmes ça fait vraiment
jeux olympiques ça fait athlètes
athlètes grecs s'est fait j'étais grec
là tu prends ça fait un peu athlètes
grecs
lien si sa fiat les athlètes grecs qu'il
faut gladiateurs presque gladiateurs
kasparov contre vladimir kramnik des
gladiateurs de l'échiquier pourrait
faire un film tu imagines un film comme
ça 1h30 avec les gars avec les gars
comme ça alors nous la différence voilà
vous montrer tout de suite c'est qu'on
peut montrer la position parce que ça se
passe sur l'échiquier voilà tout à fait
donc la tour des ces deux cours d'essai
de été jouée par kasparov et là
l'idée c'est que vient pas c'est qu'il
ne fait rien fait rien qu'à se pareront
terriens il avait 7 ou alors on va
rappeler il avait sept jours sur sept de
gazole 1 me fit semblant il déjà
transféré domicile bleu bleu femmes en
lien entre nos demandes d'irak rami
gwalarn j'ai fait semblant de faire
quelque chose peut-être qu'il n'a pas
aimé les rires dans le public
parce que les rires il les prend pour
lui car il est maintenant je crois pas
ben non il n'a pas aimé le bruit c'est
tout mais c'est possible imaginons que
les commentateurs anglais et fait une
blague pour habsheim qu'est-ce qui fait
le même constat de langue par exemple
d'un veto russe a pas l'air bon dans
tous les sens que ça devait être la tour
en prise par khalid et 4 ça c'est pas
recommandable om puis adam bessette
keller embêtant non la chronique qui
peut jouer devant nous est un peu fade
et petite chance d'amener cette dame
avis échange les dames
doivent scène je sais pas
je sais pas le pion à 6 voilà on va
montrer ses pions ainsi peut-être un
petit motif d' attaque bon mais en fait
la tour ici c'est bien placé je vais pas
ça coûte chronique comme j'ai si cela
qui enferme la tour moi j'en parle plus
passer l'idée de ce coup bas peut-être
qu'il va jouer roger c'est tragique mais
j'y crois pas je crois pas trop il a
tout de suite en fernandez pour
l'instant non mais il replace saddam
mais christophe le laisse affaiblir un
élevage à davos est peut-être comme nick
tranquillement ouais non mais ça fait
toujours rien à me 7
ils voient la preuve de rien faire on
finit par problème c'est que on peut
faire des coups un peu douteux pleine
réflexion qui se porte à plus de 14
minutes
ce n'est pas beaucoup une position il se
passe rien oui c'est d'autant plus sur
ce trophée des coûts oui non mais y
aurait là qui est horrible mais c'est
pas mal comme technique moi j'aime bien
c'est une bonne technique corps et du
coca sports aurait dû adopter bien
plutôt la technique multi cnip ça pose
sa parenté avec l animal quand on le ne
rien faire le paresseux non le
paraissent au total la technique du
paresseux
moi je pensais plutôt à un animal genre
un animal carnivore qui cherchent une 3
et qui ne fait rien donc qui attend est
peut être un des poissons il ya des
poissons dont il est plein de karni voir
les plantes carnivores caisse noire
s'arrête une plante carnivore il attend
avec toi voilà c'est ça revient vous les
ach 5 et oui non mais tu vois il laisse
venir kramnik qui s'affaiblit là
à noter que les deux propositions
d'ordinateurs dans cette position ces
tours d2 autour des 1 c'est à dire on a
rappelé que kasparov donc transférer
c'est au tour
on est sur la colonne c'est mais j'étais
tout à l'heure sur la colonne des
hématomes ordinateurs proposent les
retransférer sur la colonne des bons
c'est intéressant
non c'est sa première qu'est ce qu'on
n'a rien à faire alors que granik lui
granic en passion qui s'affaiblit non
mais ni va jouer car il veut faire jouer
son fou il veut jouer sur les quatre
marques comme nick wey mais ce qui va
pas lui même risquer de se faire
attaquer avec le cavalier qui va arriver
et il arrive où le cavalier stéphane
clair bien que les d4 et après la qualif
3 et après et après une cavale il peut
aller sur la case et bien h4 par exemple
et après il a il est là le cavalier déjà
c'est vrai on peut donc mettre le
cavalier d'une bande à l'autre en
perdant trois temps c'est peut-être ce
que va faire des sports depuis ce qu'il
veut il va en faire le moins possible de
habshan beauxis le perdre trois temps en
restaurant qui va probablement de
trouver oui c'est possible tout à fait
h5 en tout cas chroniques mais dans mes
craintes et chroniques scellé il fait on
a l'impression que c'est lui qui fait le
jeu dans cette partie oui on sait la
stratégie cta romain mais celle-ci se
disait depuis tout à l'heure c'est bien
savoir des gaspards ou ne veut rien
faire et laisser kramnik ça fait bientôt
solide mais il s'est peut-être une
technique pas mal en fait été coûteux
surprenante parce que c'est énervant
pour les noirs ils savent qu'il faut
faire nul pour les blancs ne font rien
mais granny goodness nuls la position
est nul c'est sûr mais je vais rien
faire que lorsque tu fais les designers
chronique
c'est vrai qu'ils essaient de pousser
ses pions pour attaquer résultat la fin
il va peut-être perdre ses postale de
s'affaiblit une technique carpeaux
viennent oui une technique à la carpe
aux le savent eux serpent voilà le bois
le bois qui sert tranquillement sa proie
en ne faisant rien qui l'entourent
d'autres très loin d'abord elle ne
reverra pas à quelle technique
quoique mécanique à l'air serein quand
même mais je sais pas s'ils tombent pas
dans le piège là
kasparov va jouer tour des 1 et là ça va
être superbe ça sera le combien le
quatrième tour de 1,2 alors attends qu
est-ce qu on peut assister aux caves par
exemple sur kasparov qui joue autour d
un permis que j'aurais h5 et h7 disant
d'accord si tu leur prends ton coup
c'est possible ouais tu veux reprendre
tant couvre aussi je remets mon client
où il était d'un an et n'a pas vraiment
il n'a pas le droit justement si ça a
lancé le problème d'ailleurs de bouger
des pions oui c'est ça les pions ne
revient pas en arrière voilà donc si
c'est pour ça que je joue un coup de
pioche est toujours responsable
chronique fait des cures responsables
ici a noté stéphane il ya un plan pour
kramnik quand même on va montrer
yalimapo vraiment le genre de rôle à cet
orage suite voilà c'est ça c'est qu'on
joue h 4 way éventuellement aux menaces
le jouage 3 ou de prendre chez toi c'est
à dire qu'on est souple on est en
sachant très bien que les blancs eux ne
pourront pas prendre acheteurs puisque
ça casserait complètement la pression
est dans la petite option
totalement gagnant et ensuite une fois
qu'on a fait ça au jour où un jet set et
la tour qui était en fuite
on se disait que la royal enfield est
enfermé avec sa dame est tout à fait pas
elle passe en hashemite sur une colonne
qui va s'ouvrir moyens et donc ça serait
un peu un superbe mais les blancs eux
mêmes peuvent naître une tour aussi sur
le colonel problème c'est que ça doit
laisser les morts qui décide quand elles
seront à woippy cimatti les blancs mais
la tour avant on peut jouer h trois
échecs qui enferme la tow exactement
donc ici le programme d'icc alerte
annales trawick domine et c'est non de
simples en vraiment prévu de très très
long à cavaler des deux salles et
stéphane brizé de nommer un an ils
venaient en 4k sport fus de l'avant
quatre à nîmes nascar est né le 4 c'est
vrai probablement
on va le montrer pas mal pas mal parce
qu'il y aurait des grosses faiblesses
chez noir en fait kramnik alice et
kasparov a laissé cramique permet d'être
moche mais trop absents chroniques
peut-être pour regarder les dames encore
ouais mais il a chaud chronicles alors
montre quel est des deux l'idée c'est
qu'un match en quatre attaques là les
goûts rochette attaque atone et le quai
et le fou et le fou et après le lire à
l'idée c'est que le pion c7 va être
faible alors pourquoi pas pour être 5e
stephan
et bien tout simplement parce que dans
ce cas là les blancs je voudrais le coup
très fort dames en bessette d'amendé
sept coups intéressants puisque la le
pion à six sites attaqués ils à tours ne
protège plus tu vois ces attaques et la
tour ne protège plus mais si les noirs à
bouger leurs pions et s'affaiblissent
encore une fois ça va pas ça va pas
d'accord pas que tout ramassé au projet
de 12 km à 8 mais il y aura d'autres et
ça sera pas joli ça serait pas joli
peut-être dame au cices le tout proposé
par la machine ouais je sais propose en
échange des dames ont peut-être
peut-être
ouais mais lors d'un ce cas là les coups
de pied on est noir or en été on c'est
pas grave c'est la meilleure formation
des familles ah bon si on peut la montre
et yannick yannick peuvent saluer ses
fans là c'est la meilleure formation de
pions voilà quand on a trois pions et le
roi derrière il faut faire celle-là
pourquoi il vient parce qu'en finale le
roi il peut revenir au centre donc la
signification et la vie peut revenir au
centre
ouais et il protège donc ceux qui ont la
qui protège le suivant qui protège ainsi
de suite jusqu'aux pas d'accord il
protège les ailes quoi voilà qui protège
toute l'année depuis le centre alors que
si si c'était la formation adverse
formation adverse est différent il est
le roi ne protègerait pluvio-orageux
71.5 c'est plus pareil
ouais parce que le roi quand il veut
venir en centre ne protège plus de pions
le dernier ouais ouais voilà pourquoi la
formation de chronique est bonne non
seulement en attaque mais aussi en
finale c'est pour ça qu'il a joués par
mick donc on s'est mis dans cette
position la caisse parvenir en quatre et
il a peu joué un peu vite kasparov
cavallin qu'elle envisage d'abord il
aurait dû ne rien faire kasparov
oui il a fait une menace il a craqué oui
ce qu'on peut dire qu'elle a craqué mais
oui je pense qu'il aurait dû le faire il
aurait dû jouer autour des 1 et
d'essayer de voir ce qu'on aurait fait
kramnik non c'est possible hélas oui je
sais pas qu'est-ce qui va jouer entre
amis tous rêvent simplement 6,7 hamas à
damas six médailles mais s'il n'ya pas
dame b cette dame b sat oui oui et non à
la fois puisque là est-ce qu'on menace
de prendre le pion à 6 c'est même pas
sûr si y'a plus qu'à deux reprises l'an
stéphane c'est quoi la pointe cela ouais
tu en as douce rêverie est-ce qu'on peut
enfermer la dame je crois pas et bien
jour et b2 b3 peut-être non on enferme
pas la dame on ferme pas la dame ça va
pas y'a qu'à la wilaya iv carrillo rire
les clubs et le 4 c'est pas ce n'est pas
grave c'est pas grave après qu'est venu
le 4 juin coton tours 6 et là je crois
que chronique avec un ton plus les
personnes viendra pas ne paiera pas il
ya aucune chance de perdre sa très peu
en tout cas c'est un sacrifice de pions
qui est pas qui est pas dans le débat
dans le vent ouais
peut-être pas
à alors le temps c'est ça qui est plus
important il reste 17 minutes à
chronique à il a joué tous rêvent saint
cloud il trouve cette tour à st qu'est
ce que c'était 5 ça tu vas à la question
vous êtes à l'affût mais non d'un bep
7,6 sur un nom dans le 4 2 4
waouh qu'est ce qui se passe dans cette
partie je crois pas d'âme bessette ça
m'a l'air bien dom vayssette l'un des
joueurs jouent trop subtile livret
d'amin 8 sur la machine est beaucoup
trop subtile madame catherine ans à peu
près pareil en fait d'un me 4 c'est même
peut-être plus fort que dame s qui a
passé cinq dans cette position est ce
qui n'est pas le coup c'est cette c5
peut vraiment se demander effectivement
ça a l'air fort ça a l'air pas mal
puisque maintenant la tour protège ses 5
effectivement on peut pas changer les
dames est joué kb24 ça marche pas il son
cavalier fait trois blessés cinq c4 avec
avantage noir si on avance le plan
jusqu'en c4 et bien on aura complètement
neutralisé la force des tours blanches
ouais on les aurait même ridiculisé
ridiculiser rami peut jouer c'est cette
c5
mais là il y avait fléchi crâne qu'il
aurait 16 minutes quatre amis pour jouer
dix coups contre 10 minutes à kasparov
et pour ramener le titre de champion du
monde au bout dans 26 minutes déjà on
aura une idée bien plus précise stéphane
puisque les dix prochains coups sont
très honnêtes six minutes kramnik
saura-t-il le 14e champion du monde a
menacé c'est fou ça n 6 minutes 26
minutes c'est le risque à 10 ans sur 15
ans on imagine sur 15 heures ma vie
c'est sur les 26 dernières minutes de 15
ans de règne peut-être vous imaginez la
pression même au foot y'a pas ça parce
que le coupe du monde c'est tous les
quatre ans wayne est tout à fait
et en plus au foot au fc sao foot on a
pas de champion du monde qui dure
non on n'a jamais vu le brésil gagner
trois fois de suite par deux fois oui le
mieux cette deux fois deux fois c'est
déjà pas mal soit 58 et 62 avec pelé
grand pelé qui aurait sa place ici dans
cette finale tu vas sa place dans cette
finale peut-être tu peux nous expliquer
où serait sa place mais j'aurais numéro
10 cd sans nuire au grand pelé
faux c'est la tension à l'efo dire
stéphane que le sai note a tendance à
faire oublier tout ce qui n'est pas
l'échiquier oui c'est clair conseil note
les joueurs pensent plus au titre
ça c'est clair trop tendue la pression
du temps ils ont l'habitude de ces notes
ils savent faire le vide bas où
s'esquissait rejouer à un coût
responsables comme dit à hu a les nerfs
solides
l'ue a les nerfs solides a dit
tranquille c'est le coup libérateur
après ces cinq et peut-être avantage
noir oui peut-être espoir ou va-t-il
proposer nul a noté stéphane que sur les
derniers qu'on constate que la pression
de kasparov n'est pas améliorée ça veut
dire que les tests ans n'a rien fait à
d'un programme d'un programme vient
proposer nul je ne crois pas un
attention il y avait peut-être temps en
temps dans le cadre de quatre en
question ne veut pas proposer propose
pas nulles kasparov
il a vu un plan avec f4 avec as part of
our est pas mal et oui c'est bien et
c'est bien écoute il voici fait quatre
ou cinq ça a l'air pas mal non moi avec
tout à fait parce que la case m6 va se
rebeller faible le révèle il a gagné en
quatre cases bord à oui pas mal pas mal
pas mal
regardez on y re les matelas aux cadres
de voir jouer la tour va devoir les
enlève si ce problème
m6 est là la menace des blancs c'est de
jouer jouer 2,4 alors
non alors que nous avons un invité
surprise ici à londres
ça c'est fabuleux c'est joël gauthier le
numéro un français secondes mains de
vladimir kramnik ici à vendre est avec
nous bonjour joël mongin stéphane
mondial de femmes c'est super chaud là
semble-t-il
oui on va avoir un beau finish a alors
joué et été le second vin devient dès
mercredi pendant pendant tout ce mois
exactement et tu comment ça se passe et
tu dormais le jour tu travailles et la
nuit je travaille la nuit et je ne
dormais pas de jouer puisqu'il fallait
continuer à travailler tout le temps
donc c était déjà née en partie ont été
assez difficiles qu'on s'approchait du
dénouement du match plus en plus le
travail s'accumule est donc ça nous a
pas laissé beaucoup de temps pour me
reposer mais bon c'est pas grave on a
des lasers donc là on peut dire que tu
t'entraînes de battre kasparov par
procuration bon mais j'ai déjà battu 105
sans avoir besoin d'être effectivement
alors on a rappelé que tu es le le
deuxième joueur du monde à être positifs
comme kasparov avait kramnik maintenant
donc on a rappelé à plusieurs fois et je
crois dans la donc dans l'équipe ya non
seulement dangereux à l'outil numéro un
français est aussi émis des idées ce cas
ce qui est lésé casser les barrières
donc là on était en train de dire que
kasparov aujourd'hui adopté une tactique
qui peut je sais pas grand chose et je
pousse kramnik essayer de faire la faute
quoi oui il avait plusieurs approches
possibles
ils pouvaient c'est de jouer
quelque chose de très agressif mais à
venir deux kilos match depuis le match
de kasparov et karpov sévillan 87 ou
castor à table et du jouet pour le gain
obligé de choc de gagner la dernière
partie avec les blancs on s'attendait un
peu ce qu'ils jouent quelque chose c'est
celui d'aujourd'hui pour faire durer la
partie mais bon je pense qu'il aura
beaucoup de mal à gagner parce que
l'opposition ne lui promet pas beaucoup
ouais alors là donc mais par contre ça
peut jouer sur les nerfs est-ce que ce
contrat ne peut pas craqué on a
l'impression que mardi il a un peu
craqué quand même dans les derniers je
pense pas qu'il a craqué parce que en
fait l'ouverture s'est pas très bien
passé bon ok ça va très bien arriver
c'était une nouvelle idée qui a joué de
la dîmière cavaliers vin est en fait la
position n'était pas facile pas citer
que ça pour lui et ça c'est assez mal
retourner ça s'est mal passé il ya des
partis qui se goupille mal comme on dit
c'est à dire que même si on est
correctement préparé l'adversaire trouve
une bonne réponse et la position nous
plaît pas vous mais c'est ce qui est de
ce que disait damien après la partie n'a
même pas sa position et
je pense que en fait il a assez bien
joué cette partie puisqu'il s'est très
bien défendu il a trouvé des coûts très
difficile comme h4 par exemple il a
déjoué ces cinq aussi c'est un très bon
sacrifice de pions donc je pense qu'il
s'est bien défendu mais bon
effectivement c'est pas tout à fait
normal d'être mieux se défendre avec les
bambins de côté mais c'est bon c'est une
partie qui s'est mal banque s'est mal
passé qui s'est mal goupillé
alors là on kramnik a joué le coup tour
5 et à kasparov a répondu quasiment
tempo par le cous de quatre attaquants
la tour noire est probablement il va
pousser un jouet le problème en son pion
nom de 85
c'est possible oui bien sûr c'est
possible c'est possible d'autant plus
que juste après il peut venir et son
caviar leucate pour elle je pense que
gary à vendre est d'installer son client
le 4éme rapportant que gb 3 parce que ça
lui permettrait de fixer l'option c5
comme cibles ah voilà et d'avoir une
chance de gagner parce que quand il joue
par exemple le 5 le fou s'en va on va
dire en scène par exemple si je vous
qu'avait de 4 suite là il peut jouer ces
quatre accords dont qui jouait d'abord
mes trois pour fixer les pions noirs
allaient là je pense que guy est en
train de réfléchir si le jeu d'abord b 3
ou 5 parce que si je jouais 5 fu et 7
est maintenant b3 village où la logique
cool on va montrer la position à tour
aussi s'il a joué granik attention ou
cinq mois ça boit ça joue vite ça joue
vite sa jolie c'est hyper tendu où s est
hélas castorf donc tu vas probablement
deux options soit joué carillo quatre
sages et que le soldat est actuellement
jouée b3 à b2 b3 mais sur b3 je pense
que la lumière réagir aux
investissements mais voilà c'est ça si
on joue b3 les noirs pourraient réagir
avec elle c'était 6 cassant le pion au
centre là le pion du noir à s'échouer
séjour il reste onze minutes à kramnik
8a kasparov pour jouer six coups bon ça
va ya pas vraiment de cette note
il ya un peu de tension mais nous
pensons qu'ils travaillaient ce que je
pense
nous l'a dit me en train de penser à
plein de choses en plus de la partie et
kasparov aussi d'ailleurs parce que même
quand même beaucoup de choses en jeu pas
oublier que six personnages il est hyper
beaucoup de choses bon c'est
pratiquement sont sorties font de fait
d'avoir jamais été battu en match il
fait plus partie de la fidh et donc il
sera un petit peu un peu isolé oui bon
ça réseau de soissons kasparov
évidemment il serait toujours invité
mais mais bon je pense qu il
pour lui cette ce serait un coup dur
alors la préparation pendant tout ce
match je suppose ça a été ça a été assez
tendu mais vous avez eu pas mal de
moments de plutôt de joie que de
tristesse
pour l'instant oui bien sûr bien sûr on
a eu des moments difficiles notamment
les parties où le 10 mai a souffert avec
les blancs ouais mais bon c'est vrai que
le match s'est passé de façon presque
idéale non il ya eu des moments de
déception c'est assez difficile quand au
début du match
vladimir avait deux positions
complètement gagnant est la 4e et la 6e
et 4e et la 6e à ce moment-là bon tout
le match était encore à jouer il
semblait que laisser passer deux parties
gagnantes comme ça c'était terrible quoi
parce que venir à n'importe quel moment
c'est l'impression qu'on a nous aussi on
est un petit peu mais ça c'est pas
confirmé non parce que la lumière est
tout simplement meilleur
on se moque on a une jolie aux échecs
effectivement alors sauf que cette
dernière semaine a l'impression qu'à
score reviennent très fort longtemps
avec les noirs il a été vraiment très
fort et on se dit que heureusement que
le match en 16 parties pourraient
presque que s'il avait été plus loin je
sais pas oui mais il s'est un peu une
combinaison des deux 2 chose il le fait
que kasparov n'a plus rien à perdre donc
qui se glisse dans sa faune maintenant
il est un peu libérés psychologiquement
c'est plus facile à gérer pour lui donc
il applaudit le fait que pour vladimir
la fin du match approche et que bon il
ya beaucoup de choses qui lui passe par
la tête c'est aussi si c'était la moitié
des matchs maintenant
bon je pense que vladimir aurait pas
pareil le gba mais le 13 oui je pense
que la tension nerveuse je joue beaucoup
là tout à fait mais c'est ce qu'il a dit
à la conférence de presse d'ailleurs
qu'il avait joué un peu comme ça à cause
de la situation du match mais bon comme
comme tu imagines je suis aussi le match
de très près je sais exactement ce qui
se passe d'un point de vue et chacun je
pense que j'ai joué que wladimir est
meilleure plus kasparov sur ce mot sur
ce mot sans aucun doute tout à fait
alors la b3 le cocktail est prévu joël
effectivement donc c'est ça permet de
fixer ce pion peut pas avancer les blocs
et maintenant mais par contre quel sport
kramnik pour y répondre par le coup les
sept et six attaquants ici le turc cenk
oui je pense qu'ils sont en train de
calculer tous les deux qui se passe
après six ans reprend m6 vous points 6
une petite vraiment simplement au coin 6
ou progressistes au prince et ce alors
on va montrer f6 dos chroniques par
exemple le problème 6 tu en prends un f6
faut prendre six ou prend un f6 et pour
panser s'inquiète impossible à poser
autour de schengen le cavalier voilà si
on prend le pian tout simplement et noir
font un échec meurtrier ici sur la case
eu deux attaquants le roi et permettant
de récupérer le cavalier en d2 donc
salaires donc à partir de là il ya aucun
problème dans sa mire sur réussi ce gars
il va être obligé c'est autre chose
et qu'est ce qu'il a bien pu inventer
tentatives et ses cavaliers 4 sur m6 ou
cavaillès trois peut-être tout
simplement
williams a aussi livré ci s'était joué
sur la joue et ab ça y est le jour où il
joue cavalier straw a effectivement
alors f6 et la casse par joue cavalier
en f3 ses choix c'est pas facile à
suivre
alors il reste combien quatre coups à
jouer quatre quoi jouer dix minutes
akram nixxis à kasparov qui joue son va
tout attention parce que le match peut
se terminer assez vite après le 40e coup
peut-être dans son cas sport où il va
jouer jusqu'à la dernière
le dernier pion il peut proposer
n'importe quel moment de façon il sait
que c'est que c'est faux que vladimir
acceptera toujours bon que bon lui pour
lui c'est assez facile à gérer mais la
dîmière par contre on doit être vigilant
mais la moindre erreur et ça serait très
délicat à jouer
voilà
ça joue en r c'est clair on voit sur les
images l'accueil que de la diminuer fer
concentré hier la presse entre et on
voit qu'ils ce qui ce motif d'une odeur
dans nos partis presque comme un jour de
tennis man dommage
ouais on a l'impression que l'on a vu
les mimiques de kasparov souvent
l'impression qui fait des mimiques comme
quoi si comme s'il était mal ou qu'il
avait raté un truc et puis en fait
impression qu'il bluffe pas mal mais
c'est difficile à dire parce qu'avec la
c1 c'est un mélange des deux des foyers
blog des fois c'est des fois c'est réel
et on prend qui on prend alors qu il va
prendre un vélo cavaliers il a pris avec
les cavaliers hop c'est chaud c'est
chaud alors là je veux tenir jusqu'au
bout cela je sais pas si j lo de plus en
plus de mal sur les dernières parties
alors est ce que la caisse cas on peut
pas menacer de joucas les 17 ou
cavaliers detroit pour attaquer le pion
c5
je pense que vladimir en train de
regarder fou de 6,6 pour déloger ce
cavalier de cinq ans peut-être fou ici
sa thèse les six vont attaquer ce qui
lui permettrait ensuite d'échanger une
tour en 2 par exemple est bon ça fait si
très peu mais sa défense
oui ça fera un échec le tourin par
exemple si facile des six cavaliers par
exemple en d3 que les détroits autour de
chaque tour deux échecs et là on
n'échange que les pourront se relaxer un
peu dans un peu parce qu'il est toujours
trop échec dans ce cas là ah ouais enfin
c'est notre tour de vis de france a pas
l'air bon il faudrait jour es1 non c'est
pas bon non plus et ça n'a pas l'air
bien la demi heure jeu autour de 8 il a
joué le tour des huit à dix mais on n'a
pas joué ça il a joué la tour sur la
casse dès 8 h
c'est pas mal alors ça empêche la tour
ici empêche le cavalier tout simplement
devenu en deux ou trois ans à venir sur
la case d3 ou sur la caisse 17
donc ce cabinet ne peut pas attaquer le
pion de cramique tranquille pour
l'instant
bon c'est pas mal parce que maintenant
il peut jouer par exemple pour des cinq
d'abord et ensuite sur food et 6 pour
l'escalier l'acda petit vrai saporiti
non objectivement la position est
complètement gaga qu'un problème ouais
c'est clair c'est se jouer sur les nerfs
ça joue on essaie ça c'est évident il
n'a plus de temps bon plus c'est pas le
genre de joueur à craquer facilement
donc comment ça se passe avec la dir
vous aviez louer maison c'est ça oui
c'est pas loin d'ici à mars miss oui
mais pas loin dans le quartier d'accord
parce qu'il pour préparer il faut pas
prendre les chambres d'hôtel vous vous
mettre à l'aise c'est lieu d'être
d'autres un peu isolé parce que ça
permet de voir plus de liberté d'être
complètement concentrés sur notre jeu de
plus on a des horaires de folie donc
s'il y avait des défunts domaine cd
femme de chambre qui ne nous dérangeait
ce serait gênant ça serait embêtant h41
de kasparov alors c'est quoi l'idée il
veut fixer les pieds noirs
oui ils vont coacher 5e qui a eu la
brèche liquiderait encore un pion et en
plus on se serait ce serait pas une
bonne opération pour garder un maximum
de pioche en ligne kasparov
le problème est un sport pour l'instant
c'est c'est tours qui font pression sur
ces 5 mais c'est inutile tant que le
foot protège le problème c'est qu'il n'a
pas tellement d'autres endroits où les
met les tours il voit la presse qu'il
n'a pas d'autre objectif à part l'idéal
pour lui ce serait d'avoir une tour qui
entrent dans le camp - par exemple une
tour qui se baladerait sur la 7ème
quelques pas en b777
mais c'est impossible pour l'instant
donc partir il manque un peu de plans
quoi je pense qu'il va essayer d'amener
son roi henri iii bon mais bon je pense
à un coup comme tour dessin comme je
disais tout à l'heure on préfère fou des
six jours et le coup de tour des 5 et
ensuite le coup fou en des six
attaquants lecavalier la 10ème aussi
être super solide nom qui peux très bien
jouer un coup qu'on mangeait cette épave
en danger pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
voix on va difficilement un plan à la
disposition des blancs qui pourrait
poser de vrais problèmes donc il peut
prendre le temps de consolider sa
position par rogesa est par exemple et
dans les autour des scènes pas mal bien
dû jouer un tour des cinq ici atari
enfin ça permet de mettre le fou et
d'autres pas que la taux continuent de
contrôler la monnaie donc on va mettre
le fou après sur la case des six est
attaqué le cavalier probablement pour le
chasser principe qu'un kasparov y aura
de la vie il va jouer un fait de la vie
de l'espoir il va pas lâcher le morceau
et encore encore deux coups à jouer là
il reste six minutes d'akranes je pense
que kaka sport pas va arriver jusqu'au
40e coup il va proposer mais je pense
que ouais ouais je pense que
je le guen c'est vrai mais je vois
vraiment pas ce qu'il peut faire cette
position ouais c'est vrai qu'il manquait
d'un peut-être ouais ok donc je vois tu
veux absolument voir la fin en live et
c'est normal donc à ça y est ça y est
c'est fini
kramnik est champion du monde d'échecs
c'est terminé eh bien on le voit qu'il
est content à vladimir il est super
content il a levé les bras au ciel
merci je vais lautier de nous avoir
accompagnés pour la fin de ce match et
oui kramnik qu'il est les bras au ciel
sais pas si on peut le voir la crav
olala vladimir kramnik champion du monde
d'échecs 14e champion du monde d'échecs
vadimir kramnik qu'on a vu lever les
bras au ciel
c'est historique
changement d'ère dans le monde des
échecs avec la victoire de vladimir
kramnik dans ce match deux victoires à
zéro alors que les arbitres sur scène
pour mettre en place cet échiquier qu'on
va pouvoir conserver comme une relique
c'est l'échiquier sur lequel gary
kasparov a passé la main et loi et a
passé la main garry kasparov
alalalala excellent excellent avec les
commentaires de joël lautier qui alors
viens de le raccompagner
il ne cachait pas sa joie hyper content
c'est vrai que c'est une dure épreuve ça
fait trois mois qu'il s'entraîne
ensemble
effectivement c'est une véritable équipe
c'est la victoire d'une équipe avant
tout évidemment la victoire de vladimir
kramnik qui a maîtrisé
garry kasparov à la fin historique
stéphane historique ça y est c'est fait
s'est terminée la tension est terminée à
divers kramnik est champion du monde
après un mois de durs combats et bien ça
y est il a réussi à l'avoir
garry kasparov est tombé et ses
chroniques qui est le nouveau champion
du monde vraiment stéphane champions
superbe match à l'horaire chartix
exceptionnel et là il va y avoir une
conférence de presse d'enfer à ça va
être ça veut dire va être ça la fusée tu
vas y avait d'ailleurs une fois je vais
y aller je vais y aller alors qu'est ce
que je vais demander qu'est ce que je
venais bien tu vas a demandé à vladimir
parce qu'ils comptent faire en tant que
champion du monde
si ces projets de toute façon je vais y
aller en fait je sais pas si je dois
vendre une question c'est si tu vas tu
vas tu vas sûrement trouver des
questions de se retrouver deux questions
et tu vas demandé à vladimir les bonnes
questions j'en suis sûr allez olla la
chronique est champion du monde d'échecs
et ça faisait 15 ans qu'on attendait un
nouveau champion du monde et c'est
vladimir kramnik c'est panique à pauvres
ni short niang qui se sont cassé les
dents sur kasparov
c'est vladimir kramnik 25 ans numéro 2
mondial qui devient le 14e champion du
monde d'échecs il vient d'inscrire son
nom en lettres d'or dans le grand livre
des échecs la dîmière kramnik il a
complètement maîtrisé
garry kasparov c'est le deuxième
champion du monde de l'histoire a gagné
son titre sans perdre une seule partie
après capablanca chronique qui rejoint
est capable en cas au panthéon des
échecs fantastique
misty que c'est alors que l' arbitre
eric schiller ici attend les joueurs qui
voient la chronique qui va revenir
non on a lancé raymond keane
you know my way new à non non
le web est bien la partie est terminée
mais le programme continuer loin dans
quelques instants vous aurez le résumé
anglais de cette partie phare commentée
par danny king